[Music]
in consequences of fame news Oh
submitted by Jason Giovanni who's that
one go with the why to Jason like J a
why is a am Andy Owen oh a song
something useful
alright so what the [ __ ] happens when
you become famous nine year old internet
star little tase videos got her mom
fired from her job she came from money
like what's the wise lillte is that
little girl who's like supposedly so
ballin like she tries to act hood or
something did a story on her yeah we've
talked about her so she's always saying
like my toilet cost more than your rent
or some [ __ ]
that's cool okay yeah and she's always
throwing money she's like I got muhfucka
buddy that are you haters y'all just
jealous and then she gets into her
Lamborghini and [ __ ]
but she can't drive she's nine yeah well
yes she's been posing videos on your
idea what is her mom's job because I
thought that she was old money no not at
all turns out that her mom is a real
estate agent in Vancouver oh wow yeah
it's definitely not great for that brand
it's kind of funny because she's always
saying that she's living in the
Hollywood Hills but she was Vancouver so
it's been recently reported that she got
fired from a real estate agency so this
is what's really rad I didn't even know
that what a mom looks like not they show
pictures now it was like something you
could see her in the background some on
some of the little tease videos that her
with the glasses her name is Angela
what's going on in that picture yeah
what is boys still in the video so then
I have math getting put on Angela little
taste mom what I did not expect that at
all she's the one behind the camera
record momager
yeah she's the one that so the way
people found out that she was the mom
was because like Internet people they
ended up emailing little tase manager
whatever contact she has and it linked
them to this van
Coover our phone number and then when
you search that phone number it turns
out it says real estate agent Angela
there on the internet will find anything
on you yeah they're crazy in all those
homes that she's recording in those are
not hers they are the real estate houses
other people are it's like yup because
she's always in these mansion is that
makes sense but why did the mom get
fired like what did she do wrong I guess
just bad publicity yeah the same reason
why the swedish twitter japanese loving
guy the swiss oh yeah my bed still sell
houses just not what that agency right
well so she's going to kinda probably so
when this first came out like oh she got
fired because a little taste fame and
whatever then it came out that the
agency said no we were trying to fire
her but before we got to fire her she
ended up resigning herself oh so she
resigned but they were trying to fire
her yeah i mean how did that
conversation go down like mommy can I
hold the money so I can floss like where
did that you know like maybe not even
from her maybe it was from the mom it
sounds like the mom created her yeah
yeah do this hold this because if the
moms behind the camera I've also seen
some parents that are so um kind of
oblivious to what their kids are doing
and are so super supportive that if the
kid comes up with these ideas or like oh
yeah yeah sure sure sure
yes yes I've seen a lot of that that's
like all YouTube hair English she might
not know how bad it is and then she
might see her daughter getting super
popular she's like oh cool everyone
loves my daughter like yeah I'm gonna
help her of course she must know all the
cursing that she's saying though
probably but what it's like the honey
booboo parents where it's like it's
great when she mispronounces [ __ ] so
let's keep it keep it up you know like
yeah and by the way she only worked at
that real tea for only six months and
then anymore they don't have to work
there because she probably is making
like a lot of bread on them
videos man I mean how much more like she
is little Tay
yeah but like
I don't think it's very brand friendly
so I don't know how I really know how
she would how she makes money because
she's like famous on snapchat Instagram
okay places were like you would need you
can do ads on Instagram and when does
that a brand deal yeah but she's not
brand friend oh if I if I had a Tater
Tot company I would [ __ ] like totally
link up with little tape did you know
your brand master right tater tots you
need to bring it back who eise tater
tots nine-year-olds lillte there you go
I don't know feeling that she might be
older than what she's saying she is cuz
she's calling herself the youngest
Flexer of the century so she might be
like 16 but because you're the Asian
girl she looks 9 I don't know maybe
you'd be true just a little older 11
something this is one of her videos or
so you can see oh yeah this one's an
issue
[Music]
so this is a sketch yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
her mom gave her those lines well yeah
that's some coaching yeah yeah a lot of
people are saying like man this poor
little girl her parents don't love her I
think her mom loves her a lot yeah a lot
too much her mom doesn't seem very
hip-hop though mm-hmm
she seems like she just got here from
China and she's just like yeah she could
o be so maybe maybe she likes the bamboo
is I like it because it's a commentary
on how all this stuff works you know I
mean like like if you do this sort of
thing like if like the I'm flaunting my
[ __ ] like she's rousing up the audience
to hate on her to get more attention
yeah yeah I think it's great and it's
working yes that's how stupid people are
same thing with Vicki and the girl doing
the same thing yeah cuz people because
these people are made they're made by
the people like if I saw a video like
this I wouldn't go oh my god let me show
my friends I would just skip it so I
wouldn't be a part of the people that
push these people up but it's people
always forget that they're the ones that
made them yeah her audience is pissed
she's pissing
she's antagonizing off people to gain an
audience but that's her whole she's like
let me follow her so I could just it
shows an audience of haters yeah that's
the whole idea
yeah like mainly just hate it off but it
works cuz they sell perfume and all
works like a charm an empire it's like
Paris Hilton mmm before [ __ ] social
media and all that [ __ ] she can't she
was though I think she was like one of
the first to do that [ __ ] it was all
reality TV B yeah but isn't her persona
just like one big character like yeah
she's intelligent she just she didn't
she made an accident like during the
show where she did something kind of a
blob moment and then she just stuck with
that and then from that point on yeah I
think it was Pierce Morgan or someone
who did a video with her and then
they're like that's an act right she
goes yeah it's a character that I play
that has sold throughout history though
cuz like free and Marilyn
was not dumb she was very very smart but
she played up the dumb because that is
what gives you job doesn't sound very
dumb to me and then and then you see
like Paris Hilton she's acting dumb but
she's starting all these brands like she
started a perfume line she started she
you know they owned businesses same with
Jessica Simpson she's a buffalo we are
they watch it come to Natchez a
billionaire she's doing she's doing they
all play up the dumb they get hated on
but they know exactly what that's I've
always said the Kardashians are [ __ ]
yeah I agree I agree I mean Trump is our
president and he's a perfect example of
someone who rounds up the public and
gets attention free publicity you know
Paris Hilton only got 5 million I mean
that's a big number but you know
relative to her whole family's well she
only got 5 million total out of in hit
like not inheritance but like just just
money yeah but she basically built an
empire yeah multi-millions from that and
sex tapes so good for branding but I do
believe that Paris Hilton did not want
that sex tape leave that is that you
probably could have done it without ya
that's what launched right I'm always
bummed at the sex tapes because I always
find out that they're not gonna [ __ ]
which is always yeah you know it's just
a little bit of a bummer I I blame the
whoever records it because they're not
getting romantic but then again if they
knew that they were on camera that maybe
they worked a little harder I mean
that's true cuz when I was watching the
[ __ ] one with Kim and rage I was like
why don't you [ __ ] show some
penetration and stop showing your face
like when you gonna watch this later
you're gonna jack off to your own face
but Ray J knew that he was on camera so
Ray J was rewarming exactly and Kim was
kind of doing her I wish it was a saying
- he's doing it he was what you would've
saying - have been great for Brendan
well think about that too because if he
would have integrated his song into the
video that video got so many hits yeah
he would have been morphing or if like
Kim Kardashian already had a perfume
line and then you put like the product
placement why are you getting [ __ ]
from behind you saw way more perfume her
hide her if she had her video game like
app on she's getting pounded that would
have been huge yeah wait what's you like
he turn on this phone is like video game
out while she's getting pounded it's a
picture my wife right there cuz I love
her so much
that's awesome thanks but would you
rather be that on top of the world but
that delusional
yeah like is it worth it isn't that
delusional absolutely yeah I wish that
was a little bit dumber and less
self-aware and then I I was enjoying
things more dude if I could just like
it's like no matter what I make I love
it
and I want everyone the world to see it
yeah but I think I would be so [ __ ]
success yeah yeah exactly like you're so
oblivious because you're like beyond
optimistic you're just like nothing can
penetrate your mind I do believe that I
believe it's an energy that's yeah and
like people subconsciously buy what
you're selling because like you're so
calm they're so convinced yeah cuz I've
seen like some really bad accurate like
terrible actors that think they're the
[ __ ] best
and they book things they book things
all the time and I'm like how the [ __ ]
does that person book things they're in
my class I see them acting they're
terrible but and like the teachers like
you're not good but they're like they
think they're [ __ ] really good
they book things I'm too realistic now
confidence confidence yeah Gio's
favorite and and people are buying you
because you believe in yourself you
bought yourself first copy that's so hot
being delusional I mean it helps being
delusional yeah to have the confidence
yeah once you face reality you're like
oh [ __ ] yeah that's why I love you if
you don't know that there's danger there
then it's easy to become that's about a
lot of like artists get successful when
they're on drugs
there's no danger to music or they do a
bunch of drugs they make all these song
looks right and yeah we know
I need a list I need a little coke like
acid okay acid write that down great
drop fast well have that Aaron X right
here right there you go
maybe shrooms maybe maybe all right like
all those good Beatles songs and Beatles
songs ll s do it I'm too woke that's why
I won't be successful exactly
maybe get more Walkman doped up no
[Music]
you
[Music]